we all know that the last two years were
really a battle for everyone especially
it affected the daily lives of every
working individual or soon to be a part
of the corporate world but every cloud
has a silver lightning because everyone
was at home exploring and trying their
hands on different aspects for earning
their living and today in 2022 this
demand opened the way to various hidden
but in Trend jobs or profiles and thus
considering this demand and urge to
learn simply learn has brought you a new
video on the highest paying jobs of 2022
to Enlighten you with in-demand job
profiles and to help you get a better
perspective on what the coming future
holds for you these jobs don't require
you to have a degree Yes you heard it
right you don't need a college degree to
start with these jobs
stick to the end of the video to find
out which job profile pays the highest
so without any further Ado let's start
the video at the eighth position in our
list is customer support specialist
customer support Specialists are in
charge of identifying and resolving
consumer issues while still acting
professionally and courteously customer
service Representatives must be
detail-oriented have excellent
communication skills be able to focus
Under Pressure set priorities and handle
multiple inquiries at the same time this
is typically a full-time position in an
office setting now if somebody wants to
start their career as a customer support
specialist they must have computer
skills like data entry internal tracking
and ticketing and so forth also many
customer service positions don't require
certification but having industry
certification can help demonstrate their
expertise to hiring managers
now coming to the exciting part which is
salary
so a customer support specialist earns
roughly forty five thousand dollars in
the U.S and approximately five lakhs per
annum in India so this was all about
customer support specialist now moving
on to the seventh position on our list
which is a flight attendant
a flight attendant is someone who takes
care of passengers on airplanes the
primary responsibility of a flight
attendant is to ensure that everyone on
board an airplane is safe and
comfortable
a person pursuing a career as a flight
attendant is counted as a cabin crew
member now talking about some of the
essential skills for flight attendants
are good communication skills a pleasant
personality and interpersonal skills so
if one wants to start their career as a
flight attendant it is favorable if they
have expertise in Hospitality food and
beverage service after that you can
undergo a training course and
certification
now talking about the salary
a flight attendant earns approximately
forty eight thousand dollars in the U.S
and in India they can earn roughly 12
lakhs per annum so now let's move on to
another interesting job which is content
creator a content creator is someone who
develops amusing or educational
information since most of the content is
consumed digitally content creation is
especially relevant to digital content
as a content creator it is expected of
them to manage social media accounts and
respond to client queries and comments
digital marketing materials and articles
can all be considered forms of content
creation for business
sharing content ideas with various
corporate departments to help with their
content requirements is also a Content
Creator's responsibility
now to become a content creator one must
have knowledge of SEO social media
marketing affiliate marketing you can
also try to create a network by offering
to work or by collaborating
now comes the salary
on an average a content creator earns up
to fifty thousand dollars per year in
the U.S and 7.2 lakhs per annum in India
at number five we have graphic designer
so a graphic designer designs Graphics
that clients May print or submit to
their website using both digital graphic
design software and conventional art
mediums including pencil pen and paint
graphic designers create a wide range of
visual assets including logos signage
magazine layouts advertising report
templates and advertisements they could
specialize in a specific area of graphic
design or offer General Graphic Design
Services to clients the tools used by a
graphic designer include Adobe
Illustrator Adobe Photoshop Pixlr canva
and the like
now to become a graphic designer one can
opt for some online courses join a
design community and can also gain some
practical experience through internships
a graphic designer earns up to fifty
thousand dollars per annum in the US and
6.5 lakhs per annum in India
now let's move on to another interesting
job which is digital marketer
digital marketing is the promotion of
Brands to engage with potential
customers over the Internet other
digital communication channels are known
as digital marketing commonly referred
to as online marketing digital marketers
produce advertising campaigns for
customers or for the businesses in whose
marketing departments they are employed
they work in advertising agencies or
marketing departments so if you want to
start your career as a digital marketer
you must have an accurate view of the
market one can also enroll in
certification and boot camps for digital
marketing
now a digital marketer earns roughly 62
thousand dollars in the US and 6.7 lakhs
per annum in India
so now let's move on to the top three
job profiles with the third one being
the executive assistant
an executive assistant is a
secretary-like administrative
professional the job generally requires
client relations handling information
requests preparing statistical reports
event planning and the like
big businesses like Deloitte and Amazon
employ the majority of executive
assistance
so if someone wants to start a career as
an executive assistant they must have a
high school department there are also
some certifications available such as
certified administrative professional
certified professional secretary and
advanced certificate for executive
assistant that will help them broaden
their skill set
now coming to the interesting part which
is which is a salary
an executive assistant earns roughly 63
thousand dollars in the U.S and
approximately 5.19 lakhs per annum in
India
so let's have a look at the profile on
the second position and that is a real
estate agent
a real estate agent is a qualified
individual who coordinates real estate
transactions by connecting buyers and
sellers and representing them in
discussions the ability to close a deal
impacts how much money a real estate
agent makes through their commissions
which is frequently a percentage of the
property's purchase price to make up the
majority of their income
the job requires staying updated with
real estate markets showing properties
to buyers counseling clients and the
like so if you want to become a real
estate agent you must understand your
State's requirements complete the
pre-licensing work apply for a real
estate exam and maintain the real estate
license and then you can work with a
firm the interesting part will now be
revealed which is the salary a real
estate agent earns roughly 68 000 in the
U.S and approximately 5.7 lakhs per
annum in India
now moving on to the number one position
on our list with maximum salary and that
is a web developer so now let's have a
look at it
so web developers utilize web-facing
technology to design software to create
and maintain websites and web
applications working with graphic
designers on-site layout problem solving
and testing the job requires
troubleshooting problems of the website
monitoring the website creating test
applications and the like the scope of a
web developer's work might vary
depending on their area of expertise and
specialization so if you want to become
a web developer you must enroll in a
course practice on the skill apply for
web developer options as it is one of
the most search specialist jobs in the
market
a web developer earns a whopping seventy
thousand dollars in the US and
approximately 7.7 blacks per annum in
India and with that we have reached the
end of this video on the highest paying
jobs in 2022 that don't require a degree
well which one would you choose let us
know in the comments below and if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe to
Simply learn YouTube channel I hope it
really helped you all thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here